. So yesterday I told Feud that Senate majority
leader Mitch McConnell has an opponent who
actually, well, they could
be quite strong.
Her name's Amy McGrath and Mitch McConnell,
as I've told you over the years as Senate
majority leader has been a very effective
republican operative for all of the reasons
that I've previously laid out.
And I told you yesterday and it would be close
to as important close to as big of an accomplishment.
I would say to remove Mitch McConnell in 2020
as it would be to remove Donald Trump in 2020
but as I told you yesterday, without rehashing
the entire story, Kentucky is very red.
There are real obstacles for Amy McGrath who's
a former marine fighter pilot, but there's
at least some good news early that gives us
some sense of hope and at least the idea that
this is a race that is worth investing time
and money into a Amy McGrath has raised more
than two and a half million dollars in the
first 24 hours running against Mitch.
And if you thought that Lindsey Graham's opponent,
Jamie Harrison was doing well by raising a
million and a half dollars in general against
Lindsay Graham, Amy McGrath has raised two
and a half million in 24 hours.
And the McGrath campaign is claiming, and
at least for now, I haven't been able to find
conflicting information.
The McGrath campaign claims that two and a
half million bucks in the first 24 hours is
a record for the first 24 hours of any senate
campaign period, which sort of sounds like
a big claim, but I researched it this morning
and I was not able to find anything to contradict
it.
A average donation to Amy McGrath is about
$36.
The 2.5 million does not include money that
was sent in via check checks written during
the first 24 hours, but which will of course
not be received for another couple of days.
Um, and money, uh, also pledged, but not yet
given which I don't know exactly.
Maybe at fundraisers money can be pledged,
but they don't necessarily collected.
Uh, I don't know where this started, but I
like the sound of when you do the math, you
choose McGrath.
I think that that's a nice little slogan for
her.
Also an anti Mitch McConnell slogan would
be something like, let's put a hurdle in front
of the turtle, which is absolutely fantastic,
and maybe Amy McGrath will be the person to
do that.
Uh, it's the candidate who served her country
against the guy who only ever serves himself.
I saw that one on reddit somewhere.
Now, once again, managing expectations.
I told you yesterday, this will be tough.
Kentucky is very red.
Just because lots of Kentucky Republicans
don't like Mitch McConnell, and many of them
don't.
Um, that doesn't mean that they're going to
go out and vote for a democrat.
Uh, in November of 20, 20, many would prefer
a different republican, but in the end will
either vote for Mitch McConnell over a Democrat
or simply not vote at all.
But there is a chance here in 2008, McConnell
won by just six points.
In 2014, McConnell won by 16 points.
So in a presidential election year, it was
way closer than in a midterm.
All we can do is run each race.
Graham and McConnell are two races.
I'm going to be watching.
I was tweeting yesterday with JD Scholten.
You might remember, JD Scholten ran against
a totally disgusting, xenophobic white nationalists.
Uh, I don't know.
I don't know that I'd call him a white nationalist,
but sensitive to white nationalism or coddler
of white nationalism.
Steve King in Iowa in 2018 and I met JD Scholten
at netroots nation last year.
Uh, I actually was yes, last year and I asked
him whether he's planning to run again in
2020 against Steve King and he says he hasn't
made a decision yet.
That would be a really great race as well.
So things are getting going.
I'll be telling you about interesting races
as I see them.
Let me know if there are specific 2020 races
that you want me to cover.
I will tell you it, it's difficult for us
to do a lot of pre-primary interviews because
in a lot of these races where there's, for
example, an incumbent Republican, a, there
will be six democrats running in the primary
and they all want to be interviewed on the
show and we can't really turn the David Pakman
show as I've said before, like into the California
seventh district show.
So interviews are tough, at least pre primary,
but we do want to spotlight important races
where either Republicans could be knocked
off or corporate Democrats are, um, uh, potentially
going to go down.
So let me know what races I should be following.